[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi 7 décembre
c'est le rendez-vous de l'immobilier
d'entreprise le 16e simi se tient
jusqu'à demain au palais des congrès à
paris 450 exposants parmi lesquels des
collectivités comme le département et
saint quentin en yvelines reportage sur
place top départ de la 31e édition du
téléthon demain marathon solidaire de
deux jours pour faire progresser la
lutte contre les maladies
neuromusculaires et les communes et
associations seront encore mobilisés
dans cette édition focus sur le
programme à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous suivrons également la préparation
d'un défi d'apnée à saint cyr l'école et
puis relié à paris à versailles sur
d'authentiqués vélocipède défi auquel
prendront part ce dimanche une vingtaine
de passionnés hommage à la première
course cycliste qui s'est déroulée sur
ce tracé il ya 150 ans invité de ce
journal guy gaudi et brigitte olivier
organisateurs et marraine de cet
événement et puis on parlera également
de ceux dans ce journal de rugby avec
une histoire sur le club de plaisir et
qui vient d'être publié et je vous en
parlais dans les titres depuis hier et
jusqu'à demain vendredi le palais des
congrès à paris accueille plus de 450
sociétés et collectivités
c'est la 16e édition du simi salon
entièrement dédié à l'immobilier
d'entreprise un rendez vous auquel
participent saint quentin en yvelines et
le département objectif montrer que ces
territoires sont attractifs pour les
entreprises un sujet d'oreillons
c'est au coeur du stand de paris saclay
que saint quentin en yvelines présente
ses atouts accueil de la ryder cup en
2018 mais aussi sa bonne forme en
matière de transactions immobilières
pour l'année en cours 4 6 millions de
mètres carrés d'immobilier d'entreprise
un taux de vacance à 6,7 pour cent ou
encore 250 mille mètres carrés de
projets immobiliers en développement un
secteur dynamique destinée à convaincre
les futurs investisseurs il est
indispensable qu'on soit là qu'on
rencontre tout le monde qu'on voit les
nouveautés les innovations et les
nouvelles propositions comment on peut
être plus grand tard être plus plus
rapide être être plus simple parce que
c'est important d'être simple
aujourd'hui telle simplification pour
peu qu'on le comprenne là on va cette
année saint quentin en yvelines mais
aussi versailles grand parc et paris
saclay ont proposé une conférence
commune sur les grands événements
internationaux
faire stand commun c'est aussi la
volonté du département des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine objectif mettre en
avant l'attractivité de ces deux
territoires de l'ouest francilien nous
faisons l'aménagement de notre
territoire la promotion de
l'attractivité ensemble donc avec une
force de frappe beaucoup plus importante
avec une efficacité sur le terrain ou
bien meilleur il faut être là où sont
les investisseurs puisque c'est eux que
nous chassons pour porter du
développement dans des cols dans nos
communes dans nos territoires parce que
ce développement crée de la richesse
fiscale et de l'emploi des enjeux
économiques importants donc pour saint
quentin en yvelines et notre département
jusqu'à la fermeture de ses portes
vendredi le salon de l'immobilier
d'entreprise devrait accueillir plus de
28 mille visiteurs
c'est un projet du gouvernement la mise
en place d'une police de sécurité du
quotidien dont les contours restent et
jusqu'à présent encore floues cette
semaine à la préfecture à versailles
policiers gendarmes et élus ont été
invités à faire le point et donner leurs
idées sur ce nouveau dispositif
concertation a lancé fin octobre par le
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
les précisions de camille lambert
définir le rôle et les actions de la
police de sécurité du quotidien c'était
l'objectif de cette concertation une
cinquantaine de policiers gendarmes et
élus locaux ont été invités tous les
acteurs quels qu'ils soient ont souvent
insisté sur
la bonne relation la bonne compréhension
des heures et des autres et le bon
travail en commun et la bonne
coopération c'est évidemment une base
sur lequel on peut bâtir pas mal de
choses des groupes de travail et des
changes organisées sur huit réunions la
dernière avait lu à la préfecture de
versailles le 6 décembre l'occasion de
faire le point sur les idées évoquées il
ya des demandes d'accroissement des
compétences de la police municipale en
terme de contraventions possible en
terme de
de recours judiciaires possibles et puis
aussi n'oublions pas les moyens
nécessaires pour avoir une peau lisse et
nous en armes les plus efficaces ça
passe aussi c'est vrai par des moyens
accrus notamment dans les commissariats
les tablettes tactiles
une police connecter une police mieux
équiper une police sur mesure selon le
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
dont les contours restent encore floues
le compte rendu de ces réunions il sera
adressé le 15 décembre
les premières expérimentations de cette
nouvelle police devrait se faire dès
janvier 2018
vous y êtes peut-être confronté trouver
un médecin relève parfois du parcours du
combattant et dans certains territoires
ils sont si peu nombreux que l'on parle
de désert médical est la ville de
plaisir souhaite justement être reconnu
comme zones de fragilité par l' agence
régionale de santé elle met également en
place un plan d'action pour tenter
d'inverser la tendance camille lambert
ils étaient 24 dans les années 90 ils ne
sont plus que onze aujourd'hui à plaisir
comme dans beaucoup d'autres villes on
manque de médecins un constat établi par
les premiers intéressés avec la commune
même le maire qui avait invité pour
présenter pour montrer pourquoi les
médecins ne voulaient pas face à l'est
pourquoi on avait du mal à retrouver des
médecins les médecins préfèrent avoir
plus de repos et moins travaillé depuis
les 35 heures on ne laisse pas les
conditions de travail alors avec
l'écurie fait social une heure de
travail pour faire des papiers qui sert
pratiquement à rien on fait les doubler
après quatre ans de recherche cet ancien
médecin n'a trouvé aucun repreneur à la
suite de son départ à la retraite
la commune de plaisir souhaitent se
mobiliser en faveur d'un retour des
médecins sur son territoire la ville
travaille actuellement à la création
d'une maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
qui serait complètement prise en charge
au niveau de l'investissement par les
départements et qui accompagnerait
pendant trois ans au niveau du
fonctionnement avec les secrétaires
médicales donc on va déjà expliquer tout
ça aux médecins et aux pharmaciens en
sachant que nous avons aussi une maison
médicale privée qui va ouvrir à côté je
dirais d'art du centre commercial de
façon à ce que là aussi il y ait une
série de médecins qui arrivent et
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit il y aurait
deux médecins généralistes war 3 qui
viendrait dans cette maison médicale
privée un plan d'action mis en place
avec les pharmaciens les médecins et
saint quentin en yvelines un engagement
que la commune souhaite faire connaître
aux habitants une campagne d'information
sera lancée début 2010
8es les déserts médicaux sujet ce soir
du 7 8 débat de vanessa meflah c'est à
suivre après le journal sur tv 78 en
politique c'est une certitude elle ne
sera plus le maire de saint rémy les
chevreuse agathe becker se retire de la
municipale partielle dont le second tour
a lieu ce dimanche l édile à divers
droite sortante était arrivé en
quatrième et dernière position lors du
scrutin dimanche dernier agathe becker
qui appelle à voter pour le candidat de
la république en marche dominique
dufrasne il fait face dimanche à de
liste sans étiquette conduite par
jean-louis binic et dominique bavoil ce
week end aussi c'est un rendez vous
habituel et solidaire la 31e édition du
téléthon débute demain marathon de deux
jours pour récolter des fonds en faveur
de la lutte contre les maladies
neurologiques neuromusculaires et comme
tous les ans les collectivités
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines seront mobilisés le point sur
le programme des événements avec nicolas
kirillovitch
5 millions de français tous les ans et
milliers d'illinois la 31e édition du
téléthon sera une nouvelle fois un
rendez vous important pour la solidarité
et la recherche contre les maladies
rares à saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
nombreux acteurs locaux sont mobilisés
c'est le cas des chocs ce d'elancourt
qui organiseront dimanche leur
traditionnelle est disco roller entre 14
et 18 heures traditionnel aussi les
animations prévues vendredi et samedi au
centre sportif les pyramides de
voisins-le-bretonneux ou encore les 25
heures d'activités non stop organisé par
l'association objectif téléthon manie
quoi elle l'édition 2016 avait permis de
récolter près de 700000 euros sur les
yvelines un gain est essentielle pour
soutenir la recherche en avance avance
tous les ans là mais il ya encore
beaucoup à faire ce relais les problèmes
de vue sur les problèmes
des muscles tout ça en un respiratoires
aussi en a encore beaucoup à faire au
niveau de la recherche
malheureusement le tunnel est encore
lent manifestation historique aussi sur
saint quentin en yvelines les trois
jours d'événements au centre sportif
pierre de coubertin dès vendredi soir à
montigny le bretonneux où les 30 heures
d'animations aux clayes-sous-bois avec
un fest noz samedi soir pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas se déplacer il est toujours
possible de faire un don par téléphone
ou sur internet l'an dernier 80 millions
d'euros ont été récoltés par tout en
france lors du téléthon
et à l'occasion du téléthon à grand défi
se profile ce samedi à saint cyr l'école
le franco cubain andy a cabreira à villa
va tenter de battre à un nouveau record
à la piscine aqua mundo pour l'édition
2016 du téléthon il avait conclu 12
heures de nage en apnée cette année
l'athlète tentera d'atteindre la barre
des 24 heures ni quel ennemi doro la
rencontrer
[Musique]
ce sera une performance à couper le
souffle ce samedi 9 décembre à saint cyr
l'école andy cabreira avila 46 en train
de repousser les limites du corps humain
à 10h30 précises le franco cubain
s'élancera pour réaliser des longueurs
de 25 mètres en apnée pendant 24 heures
un record qui nécessite un entraînement
minutieux des poèmes à septembre j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser de façon
spécifique à cette prof d'abdel blanche
longue et combine l'amener à sic et
l'amener dans l'eau avec des petits
palme des fois entre manga dure deux
jours trois heures sur l'objectif
réalisé 42 km la distance d'un marathon
24 heures pour tenir physiquement
l'apnéiste s'arrêtera toutes les 10
minutes pour boire et s'alimenter
pendant une minute celui que l'on
surnomme le têtard de cuba devrait
également dormir quelques minutes
pendant la nuit la plus grande
difficulté c'est les craintes parce
qu'elle y est allé fort degré de lance
de longue durée on pourra déclare dans
les pieds et donc il faut boire beaucoup
il faut s'hydrater constamment
donc c'est la pole en difficulté au delà
de la performance l'exploit dandy a pour
but de récolter des dons en faveur du
31e téléthon les animations ouvertes à
tous sur le thème de l'eau seront
proposées en parallèle dans la piscine
donc avait alors offert une soirée
aquagym que des fois ça coûte 15 euros
on fait du vélo dans l'eau d'aquabike
des concours des nages en natation des
concours de la longueur l'amener tout
simplement fardeau et la deûle à
participer à toutes les activités à la
sortie de son exploit on disparaît
colleter plusieurs milliers d'euros pour
la manifestation solidaire sa
performance quand elle pourrait être
enregistrée dans le guinness book des
records
avec moi sur ce plateau plusieurs
invités m'ont rejoint hervé barrières et
helios gracia dont 100 messieurs nos
sens
vous venez de publier ce livre une
histoire du rugby à plaisir retrace en
près de 60 ans de parcours anecdotes et
photos au travers d'un club c'est le
plaisir rugby club on va en parler dans
un instant mais tout de suite on parlait
d'apnée eux aussi relèveront un défi
sportif ce week end dimanche une
vingtaine de personnes venues du monde
entier relieront paris à versailles à
l'aide d'un vélocipède c'est l'ancêtre
du vélo le vélocipède des vélocipèdes
qui datent rond à des années qui date
des années 1860 est le rendez-vous est
en fait une commémoration de la première
course cycliste de l'histoire et qui
s'est déroulée sur ce tracé le 8
décembre
1867 bonsoir guigo dit vous êtes
l'organisateur technique de ce paris à
versailles n'avaient l'oci fed le
coorganisateur co organisateurs vous
êtes plusieurs organisateurs et vous
avez également brigitte olivier bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes co organisatrice vous
êtes également marraine de cet événement
avec qui s'appelle donc le pari
versailles avait le cip est enfin c'est
même plus que ça même à vous êtes plus
que cette marraine on va voir ça dans un
instant guy cody vous faites partie d'un
cercle de passionnés d'amateurs de cycle
anciens et qui organise d'ailleurs
régulièrement des événements de ce genre
absolument disons qu'il ya beaucoup de
clubs en france mais il ya également un
club international qui nous fédère tout
ce qui s'appelle li wc à l'international
vétérans saïkal associés jeunes et c'est
au travers de l'idc a qu'un certain
nombre de membres ont eu l'idée de
rouler à l'occasion d'événements
historiques donc le premier d'entre eux
a été le paris avignon que vous avez
cités tout à l'heure il ya deux ans tout
à fait en 2015 commémoré en fait le
premier voyage à l'aide c'est le premier
voyage cyclotouristes qui avait été
réalisé du reste par les ancêtres de
brigitte olivier ici présente parce que
des frères olivier qui étaient des
étudiants avait le pressentiment que
deux vélo avait une autre destination
que de tourner dans des manèges comme
c'était le cas à l'époque c'est ça vous
avez vous entrepris ce voyage vous avez
révélé ce suspense un peu vite mais
c'est pas grave parce que c'est un
voyage entrepris oui brigitte olivier
par deux de vos ancêtres renesmée
olivier donc ils sont à l'origine de la
compagnie parisienne des vélocipèdes
absolument en fait moi je suis la petite
fille du troisième frère olivier marius
donc c'était des trois frères qui
étaient absolument passionné par cette
idée de faire un vélo pour ça que
c'était l'avenir et ils ont pris comme
directeur de leur usine la compagnie
parisienne georges de la boulie ce qui
est également un arrière-grand-père à
moi du côté de maman donc je suis
doublement prise par le vélocipède et
puis grâce à ses fans haimoudi mais il
faut venir et pour le paris avignon
évidemment il ya plein de l'olivier
avignon donc c'était c'était une
expérience assez extraordinaire d'autant
plus que cette compagnie l'ont lancée à
l'époque il on vous avait racheté une
société la société michy pierre michaud
qui avait inventé
la absolument hélas les deux les
frères olivier et georges labouysse
étaient des amis de centrales donc il
avait une connaissance technique assez
assez précises pour faire évoluer les
lots parce qu'au départ c'était je pense
un peu difficile de manipuler très très
lourd cet add on est donc cette
industrie qui a été la première première
industrie terme de vélocipèdes est à
l'origine de l'industrie du vélo se
libère cette histoire dans votre famille
si j'ai pas de bêtises elle a été
oubliée c'est ça
du côté nantes pas qu'elle a été oubliée
je pense que mais du côté olivier mon
père et je n'ai pas connu mon père
éléments à la guerre de 40 donc j'ai pas
eu cette cette mémoire cultivée par
contre du côté de l'eau de grand père
georges de la boue lisons jour n'a
toujours entendu parler du vélocipède de
de georges et le vélocipède de georges
et les taux au musée de compiègne
maintenant d'accord
revenons à cette course justement paris
versailles avait aussi fait c'est ce
dimanche on le rappelle c'est un hommage
à la première course cycliste de
l'histoire et cette course s'est
déroulée à s'était déroulée à l'époque
sur même tracé le 8 décembre 1867
absolument et l'été relativement méconnu
jusqu'à ce qu'un historien japonais du
nom de kenzo kobayashi
la révèle puisque il était passionné de
vélo il a compris que la france était le
berceau du vélo et donc il est venu
étudier tous les documents d'archivés il
a produit une thèse en 1993 extrêmement
intéressante qui fait aujourd'hui
référence dans le monde qui s'appelle
vélocipède de drea michaud mythe et
réalité et cette occasion là il a révélé
que
avant la course de saint cloud qui était
réputé la première en 1868 avait eu lieu
cette course de paris à versailles à
l'époque il faisait très froid ce jour
là je crois savoir sur le départ ils
attendaient 200 coureurs ils en ont vu
que 150 mais ça peut se concevoir dans
la mesure où il avait fait moins de
douze la nuit qui précède et donc on
espère toujours pas cette température là
et on espère aussi de ne pas avoir de
pluie ce qui serait ennuyeux mais ça ne
nous empêchera pas de faire le trajet de
paris à versailles on va aller très vite
ce qui nous reste à une dans cet
entretien sur le parcours de dimanche ça
va respecter à la lettre ou pas le
parcours 1865 pratiquement sur le
parcours d'origine donc nous allons
partir du rond-point des champs-elysées
très précisément au niveau du théâtre du
rond point
longez la scène nous arrêter au bas des
jardins du trocadéro pour faire la photo
dans la tour eiffel bien évidemment
passer devant la maison de la radio
prendre ensuite la venue de versailles
en direction de la porte de saint cloud
à la porte de saint-cloud nous prend
traverseront ensuite
boulogne-billancourt
direction le pont de sèvres où nous
ferons un arrêt historique ensuite nous
sommes attendus à chaville par le maire
de chaville et dans le maire en titre il
y aurait également le maire de 1867 donc
une petite animation intéressante
puis nous reprendrons nos vélocipède une
trente minutes après et nous atteindrons
versailles vers midi
nous serons attendus par monsieur le
maire de versailles et après un court
sprint
nous aurons un cocktail comme il se doit
en la circonstance on le rappelle sur
d'authentiqués vélocipède datant des
années 1860 absolument nous vélocipède
sont en général en puissance 1867 1869
et nous seront habillés à la mode de
1867 et pour plus d'informations sur cet
événement vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci à vous deux à brigitte
olivier rigaudy à d'avoir été avec nous
encore casino co organisateur de ce
paris versailles à des lots 6 pen merci
beaucoup je me tourne vers un mais deux
autres invités deux autres personnes qui
sont avec moi plateau hervé barrières et
helios gracias merci d'avoir patienté je
le rappelle vous publier ce livre
histoire du rugby à plaisir 1961 2017
265 pages qui retrace l'histoire du
rugby à plaisir par dont l'arrivée du
sport dans la ville et aussi donc il ya
des images des articles plein
d'anecdotes dans ce livre comment est
née l'histoire de comment est née l'idée
de faire une histoire du rugby à plaisir
c'est très simple c'est une demande de
notre président thierry l'amendé qui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui au niveau du club si
vous voulez bon il y avait des archives
mais comme on dit personnes y avaient
mis le nez dedans dont il nous a demandé
puisque nous sommes d'anciens du plaisir
et de big love moi j'étais du éducateurs
entraîneurs et dirigeants pendant 30 ans
c'est un dirigeant historique il paraît
donc à partir de là ben on s'est plongée
tous les deux comme bon nous sommes des
retraités
à récupérer toutes les archives déjà du
club des archives municipales de l'om
est-ce du club du ce2 des archives
départementales nous avons reclassé tout
ça et nous sommes partis un aventure
pour écrire ce livre c'est 56 saison
alors vous élevez vous êtes plus
s'occuper du coût de la mise en page
dans l'ariège toutes ces voix là c'est
artix et faudrait c'est à dire que
toutes les photos que j'ai trouvé vu
leur état par moments j'ai été obligé de
tout les rephotographiées de les
travailler de les remettre en page 3 et
puis de faire la mise en page générale
au niveau du livre et de du coup vous
ait lieu c'était plus sur l'écriture de
l'histoire soit en plus de les publier
d'autres livres tout à fait
j'écris d'autres ouvrages gt est dit et
si bien que
j'ai été amené à la demande de thierry
demandé le président du plaisir b-club
retracer l'histoire du rugby un plaisir
parce qu'en fait c'est un étudiant le
passé que l'on comprend le présente et
que l'on peut anticiper l'avenir du
rugby plaisir à nous avons dont écrit
fin nous avons donc écrit
ce livre non seulement pour eux pour
laisser une trace mais aussi pour
renforcer la cohésion du club pour
témoigner de leur reconnaissance tous
les acteurs du rugby plaisir ouah c'est
un club qui vous tient à coeur vous je
rappelle 12f éducateur des jeunes
rugbymen au club vous êtes catalan
d'origine
le rugby c'est toute une scène esport je
n'ai plus rien à dire on prépare les
entretiens sur tv 70 bravo effectivement
je suis catalan d'origine et
j'étais
attaché à ce club puisque mon physio à
jouer j'ai été éducateur je suis encore
éducateurs dans la mesure où
j'interviens encore dans des ateliers
des minimes cette année l'année dernière
en juniors et en minimes
je pourrais peut-être préciser d'aller
que ce ce livre est une première dans
l'histoire du sport à plaisir et aussi
une une première dans les annales ovale
des yvelines et combien de temps ça
prendra les intégrales vous avez parlé
thaler du travail de collecte nous avons
travaillé durant deux ans et deux mois
exactement il a fallu aller aux archives
départementales veut vraiment nous avons
recueilli d'abord des témoignages des
anciennes des photos des anciennes nous
avons nous avons travaillé bien sûr
comme l'a dit hervé avec les archives du
club des archives de la maison des
sports les archives municipales archives
départementales à montigny à partir de
ce gisement j'ai commencé de ce gisement
de documents j'ai commencé à écrire des
textes à commettre quelques quelques
desserts et puis en même temps hervé
insérer les photos à effectuer la mise
en page si bien qu'au bout de deux ans
nous avons présenté le livre au comité
de lecture du plaisir au lit club animé
par le président qui a amélioré qui
apportaient des améliorations
qui a préfacé le livre et qu'il a fait
publier si bien qu'ils se présentent
sous la forme de 100 65 ou 66 pages
illustré par plusieurs illustrations 15
personnes 40 et quelques
photos plus de 80 dessins illustrent et
illustrations et autant de d'articles de
presse et une trentaine d'années que
d'autres et qui revient voilà sur les
succès les nombreux succès de plaisir
ses échecs aussi parfois les hauts et
les bas bien sûr je voudrais parler
d'anecdotes dont je n'arrive déjà la
femme centre entretien je voulais que
vous en étiez peut-être une ou deux
anecdotes une calandre est précisé que
ce livre montre
que le plaisir ubi club est plus qu'un
club c'est une famille et comme dans
toutes les grandes les grands histoire
de famille il ya eu des buts ça me
rappelle ça me rappelle le dicton dans
notre club catalan pour vivre tout à
fait je vous rejoins dans selon l'esprit
est donc comme dans toutes les histoires
de famille il y a eu des hauts et des
bas mais le club du plaisir est peut
être le plaisir rugby club a toujours su
briser les os et reprise et les bas
ecoutons-le arrive déjà à la fin de cet
entretien si vous voulez découvrir cette
année ses anecdotes peut-être ou est ce
qu'on peut se le procurer cette histoire
de se le procurer lors des matchs au
stade rodez renom plaisir et via la
boutique de du site internet du plaisir
au bic le pays et qui devrait s'afficher
en bas de l'écran non ce n'est pas le
cas encore mais le plaisir rugby-club
ses plaisirs tirait rugby tirer club
point est pour pour ce site internet et
pour se procurer cet ouvrage merci à
hervé barrières et lieu ce gracia
d'avoir été avec nous co auteur de cette
histoire du rugby à plaisir on resta
plaisir pour refermer ce journal jusqu'à
dimanche se déroule le 8e salon des arts
c'est au programme est depuis samedi
dernier à la salle armande béjart du
château de plaisir 18 exposants
présentent trois oeuvres chacun de la
peinture et de la sculpture c'est un un
reportage de mélanie poquet
arnaud ces banques répondent donner de
nouvelles lectures de la matière
pervertir nos sensations cet artiste
plasticien travail les métaux depuis 15
ans il est l'invité d'honneur de ce 8e
salon des heures de plaisir
l'originalité la qualité de son travail
la légèreté il le dit lui même il traite
la matière je dirais pour nous
surprendre et pour nous de faire
déclencher des émotions effectivement
c'est tout à fait ça ya une espèce de
subtilité de douceur dans ses oeuvres
qui je pense vont pas laisser insensible
au public pour cette nouvelle édition 18
artistes ont répondu présent de la
sculpture de la peinture cette année une
majorité des oeuvres fait la part belle
à l'art abstrait on n'a pas donné tu
aimes mes ans il est clair que
bah on vous savez l'art c'est quelque
chose qui entraîne des sensations qui
entraîne des images donc je crois que la
commission qui met ça en place d'un
réagit en fonction de ses émotions et je
crois que c'est pour ça que ça va
peut-être vers l'abstrait plus cette
année ce sera peut-être plus figuratifs
l'année prochaine il faut se laisser
porter c'est important une exposition le
public est amené à voter pour son oeuvre
préférée remise des prix le dimanche 10
décembre
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal il est
à revoir bien sûr en replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 demain vendredi vous avez
rendez vous avec nicolas qui leur
kirillovitch et sont à 7,8 l'hebdo le
journal d'actualités locales revient à
lui lundi sur tv 78 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]